Sometimes diplomacy
is downright hard.
You're dealing with
people that you'd really
rather not be dealing with.
I haven't seen
you lose it ever.
My relationship with
Madeleine Albright
goes well back before either
of us was Secretary of State.
I was a failed piano major
at the University of Denver.
I was about to end up teaching
13-year-olds to murder
Beethoven for a living and
I needed something else,
and I wandered into a course
in international politics
taught by a man
named Josef Korbel.
He was Madeline's father.
He opened up the world to
me of things diplomatic.
It's a pretty amazing story
that this refugee
diplomat basically trained
two women Secretaries of State.
When I found out she was a
Republican, I said Condi,
"how could you be?
We have the same father."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When you're a
diplomat, you need
to build consensus often with
people with whom you disagree.
It is personal,
in a lot of ways,
because you do have to get to
know the people, put yourself
into the shoes of the
person and the country
that you're dealing with so that
you can come to some agreement.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Finding common ground, working
with people who are different--
those are skills that you
can use in everyday life,
in whatever you do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]